>>Frankie: Good evening.
I'd like to welcome you to our
Fifth Annual Technology Fair.
We're so happy--
>>Narrator: There's a packed
house tonight at this K
through eighth grade school,
60 miles south of Miami.
>>Frankie: It's going to be
a very exciting night for us.
We're doing something a little
different with our technology fair.
>>Narrator: Key Largo students
and their teachers are eager
to show off the technology
they've been learning to master
over the past few months.
>>Teacher: Five, four,
three, two, one.
[Cheering].
>>Narrator: There's everything
from handcrafted racing cars
to handheld global
positioning devices.
>>Student: Mr. Tagarini went out
on the nature trail with his GPS,
and he marked spots
and took pictures.
And if you click on each of these
dots where he put on the GPS,
if you click on one, it shows
the picture of where he was,
so this is latitude and longitude,
and basically descriptions
of what each picture is.
So that's what--
>>Frankie: Our kids that are in
kindergarten, most of the jobs
that they're going to do when
they graduate from high school,
haven't even been invented.
So if we're going to do what we need
to do in education for our kids,
we need to be pursuing technology.
>>Narrator: The pursuit of
technology here has been facilitated
by several grants and a half
cent county sales tax increase,
reflecting the community's
commitment to technology
and student centered learning.
>>Michele: All right, so you're
sure you don't want that in there.
>>Student: Yeah, I'm fine with that.
>>Michele: With this kind of
technology, it's the kind of thing
that you just have
to trial and error.
You've got to get on
and play and play
and play until you figure it out.
>>Student: So, Victoria, move
out of the way for a minute,
so I can focus the camera.
Thanks.
>>Michele: This class
brings the kids together.
They have to learn to work socially
with other kids, so that's a big part
of it is just motivation and
initiative, and working together
in a group, and that's going to
help them out in life always.
>>Narrator: While technology
plays a major role at the school,
it is just part of Key Largo's
curriculum, which is based
on an understanding
of how people learn.
>>Frankie: If you know how people
learn, then you can be a better
and more effective teacher.
So we are taking those principles
and trying to incorporate them
into our teaching styles.
>>Teacher: You're going
to want a little generator
that has a gas chamber.
>>Frankie: Things like
prior knowledge,
when you're teaching a lesson,
are you really seeing what
the kids' prior knowledge is,
so all the kids are on the same page,
so if they have any false beliefs,
you can take care of that up front.
>>Student: So they're going to
need, like an air conditioner
to let all the gases out?
>>Teacher: Yeah, a lot like that.
>>Teacher: First set of directions
is, draw a bird in the center
of your card, your favorite bird.
>>Frankie: It's also based on
teaching, so there's learning
with understanding, and that
means that you create some kind
of a mental model for a
child to help them learn.
They are able to learn so well that
they can transfer what they learn
to other core subject areas, to
other things they're doing in life.
And so the-- you have to be sure
that kids really understand
what they're learning.
>>Teacher: Take your pencil
and go like this real fast,
and tell me what you see.
What do you see, anybody?
A bird in a cage, does anybody else--
>>Narrator: In this English
class, a simple exercise
in following directions
becomes a firsthand encounter
with the concept of cause and effect.
>>Teacher: So there's a cause,
the cause is following
the directions just right,
and then there's an effect, which
was whatever happened to the bird.
And if you did it correctly, the
bird is in the cage, if you didn't,
do it so correct-- do it right,
then the bird is somewhere
outside the cage, right?
Right. Now what is it
that we do in this class?
>>Student: Read.
>>Teacher: We read; so we're
going to learn how cause
and effect is important for
reading, because that's a way
that an author organizes information.
>>Student: What else could it be?
>>Student: Hair gel.
>>Frankie: Kids should be comfortable
in the classroom, they should be able
to work together, problem
solve, those kinds of things,
and it fits so well with what
we believe at Key Largo school,
because we believe education is much
more than test score accountability.
>>Student: Is it about even?
>>Student: It's perfect, it's done.
>>Narrator: To help each child
achieve their full potential,
Key Largo tailors instruction
methods and the physical environment
to a student's individual
learning style.
>>Frankie: Part of the
brain research tells us
that children have
different learning styles.
And that if we want them to do
the very best they can, in life,
in school, then we, as educators,
need to tend to what
their learning styles are.
>>Jo Ann: What are you researching?
>>Student: Pottery.
>>Jo Ann: Pottery, okay, all right,
so you want to put
Pottery as your title.
>>Frankie: There are 21 elements
that we're looking at, from whether
or not they need the light to be
bright or dim, whether they need lots
of sound, or they need no sound,
whether they need it to be warm,
or whether they need to be cool.
If we, then, in our teaching styles,
attend to those, research shows
that the students are going
to do better in school.
>>Jo Ann: The lighting in
here is a little different,
because a lot of the children that
I have are a little hyperactive.
And I felt we needed something
that was a little more subdued,
a little bit quieter and calmer,
and I do find that the children seem
to work a little bit better
with the dimmed lighting.
>>Frankie: One of the things
I love about Key Largo School,
is that the teachers
are real risk takers.
I encourage that.
I'm a risk taker, I want
them to be a risk taker.
You can't have educational
reform unless you're willing
to try new things.
>>Jeanne: Lessons.
>>Narrator: Jeannie Kurth
has been trying new things
in her eighth grade classroom
for more than a decade,
and this alternative ed class,
students warm up with a
series of brain gym exercises.
>>Jeanne: Tree.
>>Narrator: They sit in bean bags,
or on couches, under subdued light,
listening to a water sound machine.
Kurth insists that this unique
environment is a big part
of why these at risk students
become better than average learners.
>>Jeanne: When they
come into this room,
and they sit down for the first
day, and I look around the room,
eyes are here, they're there, the
slouching, the carrying on, I know,
okay, I've got my work
cut out for me.
I've got 180 days to
change their lives.
And I do it, number one,
through brain gym, number two,
through classroom environment,
number three, through the way I go
through my five subject areas.
>>Now notice we've
got ourselves a title.
>>And for kids who
have a problem seeing,
I have two large overheads here,
so that I can blow the information
up real large, it's a very good eye
catcher for your visual learner.
>>Now, if you're doing
a double line graph,
your lines can't both be straight.
>>What keeps me coming to work
every day and keeps me enthusiastic
that I'm on the right track, is the
fact that I get children in here,
say, functioning on a 30 percentile
who jump to 60, or I have a kid who's
at 90 percentile and jumps to 96.
>>Bye, have a good
weekend, my dear friends.
You did marvelous, I'm proud of you.
>>And I know they're going
to knock the socks off
of the SATs and the FCATs.
>>Yes.
>>Frankie: And I think that people
that come in from the outside,
they see this family feeling that
we have, it's a very nurturing kind
of campus, but they also
see that there are a lot
of unique things going on here,
and that does take risk on the part
of the leaders, on the
part of the teachers,
and on the part of the kids.
>>Student: Stick it in there.
Cover it, and count to three.
>>Frankie: We have younger kids
and older kids working
together on lots of projects.
We have alternative programs
that are theme based,
for kids who are having difficulty
with academics, that will excite them
and get them to come to school.
>>Teacher: Where's Oscar?
>>Oscar: One half teaspoon
Worcet-- Worcestershire Sauce.
>>Teacher: Worcestershire,
shire-- sauce.
>>Frankie: We have a fourth
and fifth combination program,
and in that program, the kids
make healthy foods that they sell
to the teachers in the school.
>>Student: We learn how to cook,
and a lot of us want to be chefs
when we grow up, and we learn
how to do science stuff.
We do a lot of projects.
>>Frankie: In sixth
grade, it is horticulture.
We have our own greenhouse, and so
the children learn how to landscape,
take care of plants, and they also
learn something about nutrition.
>>Student: Every class time we
come out here, we get the hose
and water them, or we turn
on the overhead sprinkler
that we have built in.
I think I'll try to start my
own plant shop or something,
and try to sell them, because
I really like doing this.
>>Frankie: Seventh grade is WWKLS.
>>Teacher: You have two
minutes to sign on, DJs.
Two minutes, get to
work, research right.
>>Frankie: They run their
own little radio show here
in the school every other day.
That goes over our network, and
then they also do local PSAs
for our local radio stations.
>>Student: Good morning, you're
tuned in to WWKLS Communications,
coming to you live from Channel Five.
>>Student: How's everybody
doing today?
>>Narrator: By taking risks and
teaching students how to learn,
rather than simply how to pass
a test, Key Largo has managed
to earn top marks on
Florida's standardized tests.
But for Principal Frankie St. James,
the real reward is seeing her
students experience the joy
of learning.
>>Frankie: One of the reasons that
I'm here is because I love kids.
And I like to see that
spark in the kids
and to see the fruits of my labor.
And I can see that through kids.
>>All right, let's look
into world news, okay?
>>Narrator: For more information on,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.